ted thank you for that well with
temperatures this high everyone is
turning up that ac oh they sure are and
this is a good time as well to check it
before it gets too hot already this week
repair companies getting some calls
madison kimbrough is live with what you
need to know when you turn it to cool
madison
okay well it's already 3 p.m and like
ted said it's 88 degrees so approaching
those summer months where it's
scorching temperatures technicians say
getting your ac unit checked out ahead
of the season is a make or break
situation literally
we're fan people i believe there's a fan
in every room an overhead fan and then i
was born and raised in the south so i'm
used to having the ac quite high
across the valley many homeowners like
betsy joyce cook are making the call to
hvac technicians for service and places
like bumble breeze have been busy with
house calls all this week derrick
thompson says the calls are ongoing
we're going to do a spring tune-up on
both of her systems today we'll check
all the components all of the electrical
components her compressor her fan motors
make sure they're in range their
amperage is correct
just this week the company serviced over
a hundred homes and thompson says the
key to maintaining a good ac system is
routine checkups but also having a
certain type of thermostat helps too
what we recommend is actually getting a
thermostat that will put up be put on
geo fencing meaning when you come within
about let's say two miles of your home
it'll click your thermostat on and cool
your house to your designated
temperature obviously you do not want
your system running all day when you're
not there joyce cook says she gets
routine maintenance done yearly and with
her working from home a working ac is a
must it's really critical for us to have
cool air
we have two really small kids
and so obviously very heat sensitive
as for keeping your home cool but not
breaking the bank it's recommended to
keep your thermostat within the mid 70s
of course you can also use a ceiling fan
and keep your blinds closed reporting
live in henderson madison kimbrough live
local now